[Musique]
moi j'ai travaillé surtout pour ses
infidélités et avons monté un petit
emploi à temps partiel pour un dépisteur
farce par le
c'est par la même occasion
[Musique]
avec la pandémie l'heure on se
retrouvait vraiment avec par un des gros
problèmes dans rouge plus je
voulais aller gratter un petit peu
partout à savoir qu'ils t'ont émis un
petit travail et 56
[Musique]
sera pas au travail cette vision du
travail des enfants je pense que safin
d'une spécificité
québécoise peut-être nord-américaine
entre par rapport à l'europe donc
vraiment cette forte banalisation du
travail même si les parents force pour
les enfants à travailler meilleur km
cette espèce de culture qui est
transmise
[Musique]